but it'd be nice if they're pretending
they don't hate you the ones that heard
you and they look at you
like you almost insulted that you come
up to them that happened to me like two
days ago with the girl okay I I just was
complimenting her outfit I was like oh
my gosh that's so cute she just looked
at me way and I know she I know she
heard me and then she just like kept
like like cuz I was sitting at like a a
table bar you know what I mean and she
just kept she just like looked the other
way okay then then I go to this other
place right and she's there and then she
she starts talking to me and she's like
can you take my Instagram picture I'm
like